melini mate the only guy who managed to
make a dictator chick a thing melini was
so obsessed with his image I bet if
Instagram existed back then he'd be the
first dictator with a certified account
I can't help but imagine musini trying
to get to start a fashion trend
fashionism is out darling but black
shirts are forever can you imagine
musolini is a fashion influencer hey
guys trying to make
authoritarianism fabulous again has
dictator Chic # fascist fabulous and
you've got to give it to him he had that
whole balcony thing going on most world
leaders just give speeches musolini
turned it into a performance it's like
he was auditioning for the lead role in
dictator the musical jazz hands black
shirt catchy tune about taking over the
world let's be real the only thing
melini really succeeded in it is was
making trains run on time